[Music]
I've known you for a long time and I was
thinking one of the biggest changes that
I've seen in you as a person came when
you got your dog and I remember you
approached it in very Tim Ferriss
fashion you didn't just like hey I like
me like I got a goat one day because we
saw it on Craigslist and we just like
when I got it but that's not what for
the Tim Ferriss way yeah you were like
you were taught you talked to a bunch of
people you read a bunch of books but you
ultimately end up was it 10 years ago
you got a dog four and a half years ago
okay but but it's been an interesting
pivot in your life why do you think it
it impacted you so much I think that
there are a few aspects to it number one
is caring for a puppy at least if you do
it well takes your attention outside of
any type of self-indulgent reflection /
obsessive-compulsive rumination sure and
as someone who has had a history of
depression which is being stuck in the
past and I think being highly self
referential I mean it depression is I
think as someone who has experienced it
a lot in life very self obsessive yes
when you have something in front of you
that requires and demands care where
it's gonna pee on your carpet every two
and a half hours like Molly my dog it's
incredibly anti depressive in that sense
because it forces a complete refocus I
also I think realized very quickly how
absurd some of my reactions are to
things or have been historically in the
sense that if you have a problem at work
you have a problem with your partner
your spouse your girlfriend boyfriend
you can get upset and sort of create an
imaginary agenda that they have where
they deliberately did a B or C to upset
you sure but with a dog that's
completely absurd like at face value
it's completely absurd right so the
problems are your fault it's just your
fault right so if your dog
choose on your shoes that's your fault
it's a dog and you left your shoes out
all right so a big part of I think
raising a puppy well is making it
extremely difficult to make mistakes
that then become habits right that's
that's that's an approach or at least a
lens through which you can look at
raising a puppy and if you don't let
your dog to develop a taste for chewing
on shoes
don't leave your shoes out right put
them on something or in something that
makes it impossible
and similarly peeing in the house to
avoid that you use something like crate
training and so I think that when I
became particularly in the early periods
of training Molly upset because she
wouldn't follow my instructions yeah
after an initial period of just getting
upset which i think was my default it
has been a default for a long time anger
is gonna go to emotion which here I
think is I think Krista Tippett once
said it's fear shown in public or
something like that which I tend to
agree with on some level getting upset
is fear shown in public getting angry
yeah yep and it's a coping mechanism
some people shut down writing people
learn to get angry I learned to get
angry like when I was when I was little
so doing that though with this dog who
does not speak English was so ridiculous
and ineffective that I had to resort to
doing other things that lo and behold
translate to other people and even to
yourself like positive reinforcement
yeah right
I didn't through sports and coaching and
teaching or receiving teaching that's a
little bit of positive reinforcement not
not a whole lot yeah so I've learned to
go without it even though that is
unhealthy sure and reading about animal
training if you really want to take it
seriously if you look at say training
marine mammals like dolphins you can't
get pissed and hit it with a rolled-up
newspaper it doesn't work underwater
yeah and they're faster than you are so
you have to figure out how to use like
whistles and different clickers and
means of marking the desired behavior
and then rewarding sure
and getting into the habit of providing
positive reinforcement I think led to me
doing that more I could could still do
it more with other people and like how
you treat other people
I think impacts how you treat yourself
and relate to yourself so I think that
those are all pieces of the puzzle and
last but not least feeling unconditional
love although granted very few giving
your dog food and treats helps a lot
yeah but feeling this love from an
animal and experiencing that in the
absence of language I think is really
powerful
yeah as someone as someone who tends to
get tangled in their own inner voice in
the form of language to experience that
type of deep positive emotion in
connection without language to trip over
has been really impactful for me do you
think it was sort of giving you
something to care about like to be
responsible for that wasn't there was
there's no there's no reason to have the
dog like you have the dog because you
love the dog what I mean like this
you're not getting anything out of it in
the sense of like sure you have a nice
car you have to take care of the nice
car but you know you know what I mean
yeah I think so I mean you won't you get
a dog because you want a dog it's in a
sense a very selfish act yeah even
though you can adopt and do all these
other things as I did with Molly that
one would hope have some positive karma
share back but ultimately you are
choosing to have a dog right similarly I
think having kids is this isn't a bad
thing it's not a value judgment but like
it is a selfish decision like you have
kids because you want to have kids right
yeah and I remember Mike maples who's
this very well-known investor and friend
of mine said to me he's like rule number
one with kids is like they owe you
nothing like their job is to receive
love not to give you love yeah because
you decided to have the kids right and I
think that's true to dogs as well or any
type of pet and for that reason I do not
recommend
that everybody get dogs right because I
think that for a lot of folks as I felt
for a really long time I was too self
focused slash obsessed and the only way
I could see having a dog was to kind of
wedge it into the open spaces that were
left over once I had already executed on
everything else I wanted to execute on
or fixate on and when I ended up getting
Molly I made the decision that I was
going to actually reverse that and get
Molly prioritize really taking good care
of her and then fit everything else
around the dog right and that's those
are two fundamentally different ways to
look at it and I think if you look at
sort of the realm of behavior in humans
and dogs like most animals including
humans are poorly trained yeah and to do
it well takes a lot of effort and
consistency so if someone's ready for
that then I I suggest you know adopting
ideally but otherwise I've seen people
who would get dogs and then just neglect
them sure and I'm conflicted as to how
to feel about that because on one hand
if they're rescuing a dog from a kill
shelter probably better probably better
you one could argue that's better but I
don't know I'm not yeah I'm no
professional ethicists oh no there's a
there's a thing David Brooks talks about
when his son was born someone sent him
an email and said this is his first kid
they said you know like welcome to
unavoidable reality and the idea being
that up into your up until then sure you
have responsibilities is work in life
but like pretty much anything you don't
want to have to put up but you don't
have to put up with right
yeah as soon as you take on something
like that like with a kid it's like you
think okay I'm gonna go to this thing at
one o'clock but if your kid falls asleep
at 12:59 you're going to the thing when
your kid wakes up and I think dogs have
an element of that too suddenly you're
responsible for this thing that is
totally dependent on you know and the
dog decides what the schedule is
not you which if you're successful or
self-absorbed and they're kind of the
same thing in different ways it forces
you to pivot your reality in a way that
makes you a better person I think I
think so and you develop I don't I don't
really want to use the word patience I
think it's something else maybe greater
self-awareness and resilience in the
face of the unpredictable sequin enmity
is what I think identity yeah equanimity
we could use because it's like alright
Molly gets sick I'll give you an example
like I remember one morning I woke up to
the most awful stench imaginable at like
4:00 in the morning right and I'm very
protective of my sleep historically
there like one of the best ways to get
me really spun up and upset is to like
negatively affect my sleep okay and it's
like 4:00 in the morning I went to bed
at 1:00
yeah and this is the most horrible
stench you can imagine I wake up a turn
the light and Molly has [ __ ] everywhere
in the bedroom including on the wall
which I thought was very impressive I'm
like course what possesses the dog yeah
[ __ ] against the wall I don't know
nonetheless like alright this is like
this is what you're dealing with they're
not avoidable reality our of two hours
right putting on your hazmat gear and
dealing with this and I think you
develop or I have developed to some
extent I don't think I'm the best at
this but the ability to put my better
put myself in other people's shoes sure
because in a situation like that it's
clear to me Molly doesn't want to do
what she's doing right there's something
I do this to ruin your sleep she's not
going to real nicely and it's it's it's
not just unhelpful but it's damaging to
lose your lose your husband so lose your
[ __ ] but to get really upset in a
situation like that it actually makes it
harder to train your dog effectively so
the unavoidable reality piece I think is
is a big part of it and I think there's
something to be said for the phrase I
heard recently and this scientist I've
come to know really well when he had his
first kid and he had his first kid
pretty late by his standards yeah he's a
lot older than I am so I'm like an 8
year old and I have two possible
procreation these days but he said his
brother who had a few kids at that time
said oh welcome to the human race okay
this first kid was born sure and I do
think that it doesn't need to apply to
everybody but there there is a certain
self absorption that is encouraged and
fostered in modern life that I think is
relatively new yeah that makes sense
something because we're even in a
densely populated city you can be very
physically isolated and you don't have
responsibilities or things to care for
that would that for the vast majority of
our evolution would have been
commonplace you don't know you like
you're not any kids yeah like 19 or
still you're your grandparent right you
don't live with your grandparents you're
not hunting together hunting and
gathering yeah where dogs would
certainly have played a role and did
play a role so I think that in some way
having a dog or having a garden or
having kids these are all things we've
evolved sort of co-evolved with totally
and in the absence of that you develop a
lot of neuroses which I was sort of the
poster child for for a really long time
and probably still am on some level but
less so well I think that's really
interesting the idea of like sort of
consciously developing empathy yeah is
and and how almost you could argue that
the way society is set up now
consciously stunts the development of
empathy like like the the famous one
you're like oh you hear someone else
like how was your flight no it's
terrible i sat next to the side crying
maybe the whole time then you have kids
and you're like you get on a plane you
hear crying baby you don't
oh there's a crying baby this is bad for
me you go that baby is upset like it
literally never occurred to you that the
baby was crying because there's
something wrong with the baby and that
it isn't fun for the baby right or the
and it's simply not fun for the parent
like they don't want so it's like I
think with dogs to you like you here dog
barking you hear about those you're like
oh I've been through that or oh that's
not fun for you yeah it sort of forces
you I think that's what they mean by
that idea of welcome to the human race
not welcome to the human race
you now have like may you know you're
reproducing it's welcome to the human
race you're no longer like a lone wolf
you like understand like how you
understand what everyone else has been
dealing with while you've been
self-absorbed this entire time yeah it's
also like welcome to the human slash
hominid condition yeah that was the norm
for rape like millennia yeah has been
the norms and like thank God you've
snapped out of your aberrant strange
behavior that is really kind of a new
luxury yeah that's right did you if you
felt like moving to Austin as has had an
impact on you know in a similar way like
I feel like that there is also something
selfish and strange about the New York
life or the San Francisco life for the
LA life that I've just experienced the
south and and Texas and being a little
bit different
yeah well Texas the south and Austin are
all a little different but I understand
what you mean I think that Austin has
been so far let's call it three years in
three four years in however long it is
has been very refreshing and
rejuvenating in part this is coming back
to your point about our observation of
New York and LA and so on in part
because there is no one mono
conversation yeah and that could be seen
as symptomatic of a huge benefit of
living here or a huge drawback right
there's certain there's certain
locations in the world like
New York for finance in New York you
have finance yeah true in other places
to say London if you want to be in the
NBA all-star game of Finance it behooves
you to go to one of those chances and as
a result it attracts people who are
highly driven in certain fields whether
that's fashion finance and so on and as
you've mentioned to me before I think
it's there's a high correlation between
self-absorption and professional success
yeah on some level it has to be and if
you look at Los Angeles even though Los
Angeles is a huge in reality combination
of different cities entertainment is the
the predominant mono conversation
whereas here in Austin you have more of
a medley yeah and for that reason I find
it I find that I don't overtax a single
sort of conversational track or part of
my brain like you can quite easily hop
from lily pad to lily pad and maintain
some degree of mental dexterity
emotional dexterity there's just there's
just more to easily dip your toe into
here yeah and it does exist in a place
like San Francisco but it takes more
effort to avoid the mono conversations
don't you think one of the downsides of
the mono conversation is also let's call
it mono thinking right so I think I
think we have tended these days to
define diversity as merely a function of
race or gender but I think diversity as
far as lifestyles thinking careers
interests you know it is is also super
important the main downside of the mono
conversation is mono thinking
and a groupthink that produces an echo
chamber that at least in my experience
doesn't stress test a lot of your own
beliefs because you end up succumbing to
this preaching to the choir yeah and
that I think is things very dangerous
yeah I think it's very dangerous I think
in Silicon Valley where you have so much
capital and so much power so much
culture shaping technology that you
really want to have not necessarily a
court jester but someone who can poke
fun at the status quo and challenge
deeply held beliefs or I should say
better yet deeply assumed beliefs yeah
and that is very increasingly difficult
to do in the Bay Area and in much of
certainly culture in the United States
and we're in Austin yeah which is
jokingly referred to as the blueberry
and the tomato sooo yeah right yeah the
blue dot in the red ocean yeah yeah and
so it is a one might think that Austin
is just a smaller version of San
Francisco but it's not yes it's you do
have a Camila of political artistic and
financial interests yes that I deeply
enjoy and the the ability to easily for
instance I mean we were we're sitting
here right above a restaurant called
Jeffrey's and next door is josephine
house and i had dinner at josephine
house with someone i won't mention my
name
most people wouldn't recognize him but
an extremely successful investor a
financier who came in from out of town
came in from elsewhere in texas very
well-educated extreme
really smart and also a staunch
Republican on many levels not all levels
right it's easy to paint with that broad
brush and when you have the ability to
sit down someone like that easily here
it becomes harder to do what is so
frequently done in San Francisco as a
place where I yeah it's been a lot of
time you know almost two decades in the
Bay Area to say oh right where's our all
knuckle-dragging idiots yeah it becomes
much more difficult to paint as you know
my direct first-hand experience that
that's not true it's not that it's not
true in many cases and it's just not
that simple
right right it's just not that simple
and it forces you to contend with I
think a mess a reality that it behooves
all of us to recognize as messy yeah it
just requires more thought but I like
the fact that it's it's not as easy to
kind of divide this country into like a
left-right civil war yeah of smart
versus dumb rich versus poor this versus
that it's not that it's not as easy to
do here and I like that yeah I also
think that it would be difficult for me
to live in many places outside of Austin
in Texas sure right which is not a
slight against Texas it just means that
Austin has a combination of factors it's
the combination of factors that makes it
interesting to me and the fact that it
has some of the ingredients and we'll
see if this backfires over time it might
but that made Silicon Valley Silicon
Valley you have you know you have large
famous research universities with
world-class talent from dozens of
countries around the world and and it
attracts a very intellectual crowd yeah
and as you and I know there is an
incredible writing scene here there's
some fantastic writers and it has a lot
of the ingredients I like it
Silicon Valley without these or smug
yeah self-satisfaction that I find so
unappetizing you know what I think's
important of what I was sort of like
thinking about places to live is like
you're naturally a competitive person is
sort of keeping up with the Joneses part
of it like it's very easy for life to
become an arms race right and when you
live in a place with more diversity
where you live where there's not sort of
one industry or one scene that dominates
all the others yeah you become more
inwardly focused on what you want to do
and what's important to you rather than
going oh did you hear what so-and-so
just got you know you know like and I
think that's a healthier way to live
also yeah that's I think that's a very
good observation there's no one lead dog
to follow yes right and as a result you
have to make more conscious decisions
about who you might want to emulate it's
not an immediate default yeah
and I like that I also don't know if
Austin would be the right place to live
it probably wouldn't for many industries
if you are in your 20s and looking to
cut your teeth yeah and make your mark
and kind of summit the mountain
sometimes you need that to drive you
forward but that maybe isn't how you
want to spend your whole life yeah I
think that there's a point at least
there was for me where you've you've
basically alternated between Park and
sixth gear and like oh wait
there are five other gears yeah I don't
actually need to have this binary
lifestyle that is either like rest and
recover or full-out
sprint for the Olympic gold medal there
are actually all these gears in between
that allow you to experience an enriched
life in Merrion other ways that were I
geographically located in one of these
no-holds-barred Taipei city's I probably
wouldn't give myself the
slack in the system to discover I would
like to think it doesn't matter where I
am yeah I can cultivate all these
amazing habits and types of awareness
that will allow me to blah blah blah
blah blah but the reality is I'm highly
flawed with all sorts of predispositions
and I am to my benefit and often to my
detriment highly highly competitive yeah
so if I'm if I'm thrown into any game
even if it's stupid game that I
shouldn't participate when I win I'm
gonna win I'm gonna want to win and
recognizing that is important I remember
having Peter Thiel on the podcast long
ago listen yeah yeah and I believe I
don't remember the context exactly but
one of the questions and I'm
paraphrasing here I believe one of the
questions he asks himself is in what
areas of my life can I be less
competitive yeah to be more satisfied or
more content yeah and if your default is
competition but I think it pays huge
dividends to be aware of that and to ask
those types of questions my favorite
line from him is that competition is for
losers competition is for losers
no but I think what is interesting about
you those you are a very competitive
person and yet this is something I wrote
down to ask you about you have a habit
of walking away from things that you're
at the top of right so like I craft
never wrong but I think your decision to
sort of stop angel investing or stop
actively angel invest coincides with
their decision to move to Austin or the
overlaps yeah very very much an overlap
yeah 2015 and then she will either after
so how how much what what I'm curious
about your decision to sort of you know
you're not putting out a book a year
even though you could make a lot of
money and sell a lot of copies that you
sort of have have sort of been
disciplined about what you don't do but
how much of that is also related to like
designing a life or a day-to-day reality
you know how much are how much are they
connected I think they are all really
into
related and I'm not gonna try to
fabricate some grand master plan because
yeah I don't have one but I do think
that I tend to pause and try to reflect
and ask a lot of questions when I feel
that my decisions in any area of my life
begin to bleed into fear of missing out
or scarcity right or fear-based
decision-making not perfect but in the
case of angel investing and the reason I
stopped effectively all of it in 2015 or
so is that I realized the conditions
were becoming more difficult to place
effective bets especially as an
individual using their own capital
versus a fund with a nice like 2%
management fee and 20% carry when you're
using other limited partner money which
is a PHY model and I don't have an
ethical issue with it but I I realized
that to do a good job with an
increasingly increasingly high number of
decks in the blackjack game yeah in the
form of bloated terms higher prices
foreign capital flight from places like
China coming into the u.s. and affecting
terms I would either I could no longer
do an effective job part-time yeah and
that I if I wanted to continue to
compete in that game I would need to
create a fund that do it semi full-time
and in that world I would be effectively
replaceable I would be in a long line of
people trying to do the same thing and
that my drive to do that would be
predominantly driven by fear of missing
out and a I think a sort of cortisol
driven scarcity mentality that is really
fostered in the world of startups and
even if I were to win that game I felt
like the toll
would take would not be worth the sort
of Faustian bargain and in other words
from a mental health perspective from a
physical health perspective from an
emotional health perspective that that
it would do it would end poorly
and I tried to do to make a realistic
assessment of my track record and angel
investing which has been very good to
date but a lot of its on paper and I
began investing around 2008-2009 I was
like okay so if we flash forward that's
about six years many of these bets and
the the jury's not out until the final
of a wire transfer comes in until the
wire transfer comes in and that final
outcome for many of the startups that
you bet on will take 7 to 12 years yeah
so looking at that timeline I thought to
myself well I've placed between 50 and
70 bets I'm not yet convinced that I'm
good at this so why would I commit to
doing this full-time if I'm not yet
fully satisfied that I am good at this
right or that things are sufficiently
influenced by elements under my control
that I can help steer outcomes Yeah
right you could be the best at picking
the initial horses but by the end of the
race if they're falling apart it doesn't
make a difference so these are all
questions I thought about and that in
addition to many other things a very
close friend of mine asking me to please
not stop writing yeah since come alright
yeah come on round got great guy given
the feedback that he'd seen at events
with readers of mine and he said you'll
never have that impact investing right
so please don't stop writing and those
all then coincided when I asked many of
those questions which were uncomfortable
because I've done very well financially
an investing I've done better and
investing by far than I have in writing
and I'm sorry fields are more lucrative
than other yep field success yes created
equal yeah for sure and if you're if
you're trying to get rich when people
are like I'm just gonna sell a few
million copies of books I'm like god
bless you good luck because that is a
really
it's difficult to make that math work
yeah they're far easier ways to make
money when I begin to ask those
questions I realized that much of my
being in the Bay Area was predicated on
maintaining and building a competitive
advantage in investing right you removed
the investing here and you look at your
surroundings with fresh eyes you're like
what wait a second a lot of my best
friends have left so my social reasons
for being here are fuel to none
yeah not nothing but a few if I remove
the investing my professional need to be
here is non-existent sure so why am I
here yeah what do I like what do I
dislike and a lot went into the decision
but led me to consider a number of
different places but predominantly
Austin which I wanted to move to right
after college just didn't get the job
ecology software and if you look at some
of these decisions they're almost all
catalyzed by a breakdown of some type
yeah I'm wearing out some type of
burnout yeah that happened with the
4-hour chef leading to podcasting yeah I
was flamed out because I tried to do it
what should have been a three or four
year project in a year or a year and a
half which was a suicide mission and
that that extreme pain and burnout then
led to test-driving podcast right right
so a lot of my walking away at the top
so to speak I would like to say is this
sort of grand philosophical insight and
like balls of steel and you're not
looking at the pile of chips and going I
have enough let's walk away you're
actually going this is awful I'm
miserable it's often those yes right but
it starts with this is awful and
miserable right so it's sort of the
breakdown equals breakthrough I'm
borrowing that from someone that is
catalyzed by wearing out yeah and I
suppose where I've been fortunate are
made some good decisions is instead of
just plowing through that sometimes it's
physically impossible
[Music]
I will say I have enough chips where I
don't need to race into the next
decision let me take some time to
journal journal journal journal and I do
a lot of journal journaling asking
questions I don't find my thinking to be
clear at all unless I'm writing yeah and
I think Kevin Kelley was the one who
said this to me amazing guy then he
doesn't write to put his ideas down he
writes to think
writer as a means of thinking and in
doing that I then have looked at options
like stopping all angel investing yeah I
like to ask these absurd questions what
if I left the bear entirely moved to
Austin Texas and I think that another
reason I've been comfortable pulling a
trigger on a lot of these things trying
the podcast is that I view them all as I
don't know why it seems I don't know why
I find this so easy but a lot of people
find it hard I'm not sure why that is
I think it's practice predominantly like
what would it what would a meaningful
but reversible experiment look like
that's it right ok with the podcast I
committed to I think it was six episodes
yeah then if I don't like it I can walk
that's that's it and with Austin it's
like you can always I can always move
back to the bear area yeah my
realization is oh my god I didn't
realize how much I loved these things I
down this I can always move back it's
it's completely reversible I think it's
a great because I remember I was asking
you recently for some advice in
something that was like sort of a big
purchase it would be a big lifestyle
transition and you're like wait how else
are you gonna find out if you want to do
it or not and you said like why don't
you just commit to doing it for two
years and and it's totally right cuz I
remember when I dropped out of college I
was like I'm dropping out of college
that's the biggest decision I've ever
made in my life yeah I remember I went
to someone there like you know you can
go back right and it like it didn't even
occur like even when I went to drop out
I was like I'm here to drop out they're
like you lit there's not a forum for
that there's a take a semester off form
you know but we think these lifestyle
decisions are irrevocable and
life-altering and really they can start
very small they can start early so on I
want to
just highlight something you just said
which which I think it's missed often
time in the romanticizing about dropping
out yeah of college that for many of the
folks who are like the name-brand
Titans who have adopted dropping out of
college as one of their favorite stories
and drums to beat if you have the the
Zuckerberg the teals or whoever might be
all the teals not a great example of
dropping at himself but yeah you talk
about these incredible icons of
entrepreneurship who dropped out of
school it's really important to realize
that when you drop out of Harvard or
Stanford different those
administration's effectively say come
back anytime you want yeah and that is
really important
it's a footnote that people need to be
yeah although what I would add to that
is I actually think the Zuckerberg Zand
the gates are proof of the experimenting
thing right because I hear from people
who want to drop out of college I'll
attend early I'd like to be an
entrepreneur I want to drop out of
college
Mark Zuckerberg left college because
Facebook was successful right right
he wasn't dropping out of college to
then go start the Facebook yeah and so
it you can do the thing now and then if
it's working you can transition away
from you can decide to go hey what would
it look like if I am if I committed
full-time to this for six months what
would come of that and I think it's not
like you've never been to Austin before
and you sold everything you you own and
you were like I'm gonna see if I like it
like you can experiment you you dip your
toe in these things in a bunch of
different ways and then yeah you are
jumping off a cliff but there's also an
exit strategy yeah I I almost never burn
the ships yeah yeah I can't think of
offhand a single example of me burning
the ships and throwing caution to the
wind and just yeah leaping into the
unknown that's just not how I do things
and because you don't need to do them
that like people I think you don't need
to do that it's and I invite you I think
moat that means most people like yeah
most people should not sort of jump
headfirst into the shallow end and hope
that they figure it out I think it's a
terrible idea and if you look at some
the the entrepreneurs who were thought
of as these swashbuckling risk-takers
Richard Branson Sir Richard Branson and
had on the podcast as one example
they're actually when you peek under the
hood and start looking at the details
they are better called experts and risk
mitigation and capping the downturn
right yeah well like he figured out how
to lease plans I think from Boeing might
have an air bus for Virgin Atlantic yeah
and set up a structure such that the
financial risks usually associated with
Airlines were dramatically mitigated yes
and he made a lot of exciting unusual
bets most of which were survivable bets
Yeah right
yeah Jeff Bezos says I don't believe in
fact the company bets yeah he's like I
want to be constantly taking risks small
risks that are survivable I don't want
the if this doesn't work we go out of
business risk he's like you've waited
too long if you have to take those risks
yeah
dan is dimensioned with Austin I mean I
had been to Austin 15 times yeah I had
spent increasingly long periods of time
here
each trip to South by Southwest so I had
already done more than dip my toe in the
water yeah then it was really a question
of whether I would enjoy living here I
knew I enjoyed being here yeah right I'm
short periods of time would I enjoy
living here which is a whole separate
question and there are ways to test yes
so I think my comfort with walking away
at the top is a result of a high degree
of comfort with and a large amount of
practice in thinking about my life as a
series of experiments yeah and it's it's
also just being a student of recent
history right look at Dave Chappelle see
what it's crazy walk away from 50-member
and then he comes back he does I don't
know what the numbers are exactly well I
have $100,000,000 the Netflix yeah Dave
smells fine yeah sure and
people who really focus it being good at
their craft can almost always come back
no no one I can't remember who said this
this isn't read mentors but someone said
you know Will Smith doesn't do a movie
for two years people aren't like
whatever happened to Will Smith right
right Will Smith can take all the time
you want yeah and I I think that
underscores the importance of just
focusing on being as good as possible at
your craft yeah that's a cow Newport
thing like if you're so good they can't
ignore you you get to dictate your terms
yeah yeah and I am extremely risk-averse
risk defined as something with a hot
with a high likelihood of an
irreversible outcome yeah the bet the
farm yeah so do you have any strategies
for mitigating like what if you're
thinking about doing something what do
you look at to sort of separate good
risk and bad risk good risk for me has a
few characteristics my two of the key
characteristics would be hi hi 90 plus
percent likelihood of developing
developing or deepening skills that will
transfer to other things okay whether
now or in the future even if this
project fails another characteristic of
good risk would be developing
relationships that can transcend this
project yeah even if it fails and this
is borrowing from Scott Adams quite a
bit the creator of Dilbert who talks a
lot about this type of thing how to win
even if a project fails another
characteristic of good stress would be
something that will help me to develop
attributes or emotional resilience or to
take things less seriously which I think
often go together yeah right to try
something that is scary to me or to most
people that I can demystify in such a
way that it's less intimidating yeah
right the podcasting and doing six
episodes is a great example yeah
the beginning the idea of podcasting in
my head was having this big studio and
all this equipment and it's This
American Life or the staff 40 people and
no it's not after six episodes like oh
alright
actually I'm not scared sure my audio at
all yes these mics these cables so the
recorder that's on this chair yeah like
500 bucks and you're right locked and
loaded and the editing is actually
pretty straightforward so those are
three characters of good risk and then
bad risk I think is largely a function
of allowing unknowns that don't need to
be unknowns and so I do a lot of
homework for many of my bets if I'm
looking at say Austin okay I want to
understand what the landscape political
legal and so on looks like in Austin I
want to look at population growth I want
to look at employment growth yeah I want
to look at median home costs yeah and
how prices are moving not just in Austin
but compared to my other options on the
table so the opportunity cost of it it's
a relative decision it's not an absolute
decision yeah because and I'm also gonna
look at let's say if I stay in a San
Francisco what are what are the risks of
the status quo yeah like what are the
knowns that I dislike and then what are
the possible changes that I might just
like so not just looking at the the
potential upside and downside and pros
and cons of the new option but comparing
it to the current option that sounds so
self-evident but it is not common
practice right most people just assume
all right this is my known and I'm gonna
look at the risks and pros and cons of
this a new option I'm always looking at
relative I'm looking at not just
opportunity cost but the sort of
relative attractiveness right and that
can apply to just about anything I mean
it can it can apply to startups
certainly and the in terms of bad risk
I do look at a financial risk I look at
reputational risk I look at legal
liability risk and I do I do I do more
comprehensive risk assessment than I do
opportunity assessment in part because I
want to look for a symmetric sure that's
yeah in the sense that if I know I can
count my downside that there is little
or I can manage or completely eliminate
reputational legal risk by asking for
let's say an indemnity clause and having
a written record of what we agree my
responsibilities will or will not be and
I'm putting in fifty thousand dollars
yeah in a sense if I can control my time
that is allocated to this my max
downside risk is fifty percent right but
if I'm investing in
software-as-a-service fifty thousand
sorry if they have thousand dollars if
though I'm investing in a sector and a
vertical and a type of company like
software-as-a-service or whatever that
has comparables which show a hundred x
returns a thousand X returns I'll take
that bet all day long yeah
right if the team and so on sure give it
a reasonable likelihood of success that
is a great asymmetric bet and I think
you can do that outside of investing in
startups I think investing helps to hone
the questions you ask and the types of
lens through which you look at things
and how you might consider arbitrage and
so on but like Austin for me is a very
it's a very simple bet where it's easy
to cap the downside it seems to me
that's the main strategy in your life is
its capping downside so it's like okay
you put $50,000 into startup the most
you can lose is fifty thousand you spend
five hundred thousand dollars on a real
estate investment you're responsible for
the cost of maintaining the property you
know like it's a it's a totally
different and so
and I think that that explains your
experiment thing so it's not I'm
starting a podcast now I have to have a
podcast forever you're thinking I'm
committing to six so the most if I don't
like it the most I have to do is six
episodes of something I don't like yeah
do you know what I mean you're you're
capping you're capping so it's not
endless amounts of losses whether that's
time resources happiness money yeah and
I always try to cultivate walkaway power
with my own projects how do you do that
I'll explain or try to explain why I
think it's important first if if I feel
like I have to do something you lose
your optionality you haven't and
furthermore you begin to make decisions
out of fear or guilt which in my
experience turn out almost always turn
out poorly yeah similar if you're making
decisions at a prestige can turn April I
think I borrowed that from Maria Popova
and what she said once on the pot on the
podcast but cultivating walkaway power
is a function for me of a revisiting how
little you actually need very quickly
yeah this is Seneca yeah Seneca not tea
Moore's poppers hots but you know I'll
set aside a certain number of days each
month or whatever it is to get by with
thus Cantus scant astir scanty estai
always messing it up affair but
practicing periods of poverty or it's
like knowing being okay with the rock
bottom I'm making a making dude I just
did this last week I'm making do for a
while with like instant coffee and a
oatmeal and a bag that you cook we have
boiling water yeah and everything's
great and granted it's different when
you do it for an extended period time
it's different if that's your only
option nonetheless constantly revisiting
and confirming how little is actually
needed is number one number two is doing
fear setting this exercise that it
talked quite a lot about which is of
course borrowed directly from stoicism
and cognitive behavioral therapy which
is also largely based on a stoic
philosophy of what is the term in Latin
it is meditative yeah yeah meditation
malorum meditating on the the possible
evils or risks so I have a written
format for your setting people can check
out teamed-up blog for slash Ted if you
want to see what that looks like it's
all free I do that routinely so we're
recording this in January 2020 and I did
a lot of feature setting around talking
how poorly this conversation of the
writing could go and how I would
possibly repair them an incredible
reputational damage around stopping just
about everything so even though I'm not
seriously considering or do I feel
compelled to say stop stopping the
podcast I would write down like stop the
podcast question mark what if I stopped
this what if I stopped at all
involvement with real estate what if I
stopped all travel sure what if I
stopped and now I will go through the
thought experiment of what if I
completely stop these various things
categorically and when you run through
the kind of so what so what so what so
what
yeah each of those ultimately you
realize you're gonna be [ __ ] fine
yeah
with all of them sure and to that extent
I think that making good decisions is
often negotiating with yourself and that
the person you want to have win that
negotiation and this is advice I got a
long time ago is the person who cares
the least and that's not a value
judgment but if you have two people
negotiating against each other and one
feels like they have
do the deal yeah and the other person
has a has 20 different batas right best
alternative to negotiated agreement and
they don't give two shits whether the
deal happens or not or at the very least
they're very comfortable walking away
yeah he or she who cares the least wins
yeah and I like to cultivate the side of
me they can see how little a lot of the
glossy veneer aspects of life add at the
end of the day to like the core of what
you need to feel content on a regular
basis
so that might be a lot of word salad at
once but the those are at least some of
the ways that I think about it no I
think that ties into we were just
talking about the Stokes Marcus Aurelius
has this thing he says like ask yourself
at every moment is this necessary like
what you're thinking what you're doing
what you're desiring is this necessary
and that seems you used to have a sign
in her house that said like simplify
still have it yeah that seems like you
guys are in online that you're like how
do I need this do I want this what would
happen if I didn't have it
why does everyone else want it it seems
like you're constantly questioning that
I am or trying to do it at regular
intervals and I get caught up in the
sketch dream and starts swimming against
the Riptide all the time and I get
sucked into stuff all the time but I do
very frequently take plane rides and so
on to journal and to also try to
identify this is relatively new I mean
in the last few years but especially
crossing 2020 and looking at not just
2019 for the last decade yeah and the
better decisions that I had made and the
poorer decisions and that I made which
which are different from good and bad
outcomes yeah it was like right but just
the
so where I made mistakes and
decision-making and some of the sort of
catastrophes and things that really cost
me a lot of angst and upset
one of the corollaries is i to the bad
decisions was that or correlations or
others that I wasn't paying attention to
energetic management or like energy
management and I'll explain what I mean
but though so it's in your own energy
yeah it's pretty simple I mean as I get
older I still feel like I'm in good
shape
yeah but if I don't sleep well for two
or three nights yeah life is not good
right generally right and that's a
really simple example but the the point
being when I'm considering doing a
project partnering with someone
embarking on some type of creative
endeavor the the question that I'm
trying to ask myself now is over the
intermediate or a long term which to me
could be you know three months yeah
uh-huh will this give me more energy or
take away or deplete me if more energy
sure and so it's not like the hell yes
or hell no it's like what is this do to
my energy levels yeah which are which
are closely related but it's but yeah
some of the some of the things that give
me a lot of energy are not necessarily a
hell yes
right there yes like swimming regularly
yeah this is a great time for that it is
a great time for that yeah yeah you look
Barton Springs yeah it's a great great
location there are a lot of pools here
so swimming regularly I always feel
better and I always feel more energized
I feel more emotionally resilient sure
absolutely yeah and it's not a hell yes
like for some people going to Burning
Man for the first time or something
right it's not that I like chocolate
cake hell yes no it's not that volume or
like jump up and down on the table hell
yes but it is a great investment for
building up energy reserves yeah and so
I've tried to make more and more
decisions keeping that in mind yeah and
turned down a lot of what on paper would
look like fantastic opportunities
because it will involve dealing with a
huge bureaucracy which I know is going
to drain my batteries and historically
has always drain my batteries it's like
you know it's it's it is on paper a
great opportunity but this is gonna take
10 times longer yeah
then it's specked out to take and it's
gonna be draining and I would much
rather do something smaller that doesn't
have that effect on my energy even
though one could argue that this would
be better for my career whatever the
hell that happens to be I still don't
know it well I think that's I think a
lot of you were talking about the
difference between good and bad
decisions is not the same as good or bad
outcomes and so I think a lot of people
make decisions and I do this but I have
to counteract it but we feel like is
this gonna make me more or less money is
this going to make me more or less
famous is this gonna make me more or
less successful is it's gonna make me
more or less interesting we think about
the outcomes yeah and and often that
outcome is very far in the future and
very much the decision isn't it isn't
like if you do this you are guaranteed X
you know or if you do this for
guaranteed X it's like hey if you
continue to do this over and over again
you might get this thing in 20 years
yeah and I think one of the things I
took from the 4-hour workweek and that
I've gotten from you regularly is you
tend to think more about like quality of
life right now so don't work a crappy
job that you hate so in 50 years you can
retire and go to the beach think about
what decisions you can make now that
give you the access to the beach in the
in the intermediate or shirt short-term
so I tend to think more like as an
experiment yes specifically yes because
you may get I hate to the end of the
line you're like oh [ __ ] I actually
don't like sailing totally and this was
my made up to him for 50 years for which
I sacrificed all these other things yeah
so I think it's like is this giving me
like day-to-day what I like more or less
you know so that your your that's my
version of the energy thing is like am I
having the time and the life that I want
not am I
doing this so maybe I get that in the
future and it seems like as a person who
popularized this lifestyle design that's
kind of your core message it's like are
you designing a life you actually like
living in that is that is a think a huge
piece of it and if we wanted to parse
that out even further it's it's really
trying to cultivate an acute awareness
of knowns and unknowns and if you look
at lifestyle design for people who
aren't familiar with the term so
lifestyle design would have effectively
be a contrasting sort of philosophical
lens through which to look at career and
personal development that is juxtaposed
with the the kind of slave safe retire I
am going to cash in my chips in 20 30 40
years that will then redeem this period
of doing many things that I disliked
okay which is not to say you're always
going to enjoy doing everything yeah
like I don't know many people who love
doing their taxes yeah there are things
that you need to do but I don't know how
it gets exactly what they want when
they're 20 years old where I don't even
like you have to earn and build and yeah
invest yeah there's a there's a period
of testing that goes on to determine
where you are particularly adept looking
at we don't do to have to rehash of the
book but suffice to say there are ways
that you can test the and should test
the hypothesis that in X period of time
when I do Y it is going to give me a Z
amount of pleasure that will make up for
these decisions I'm making in the
interim that is a that is a very
contingent that is a fear that is
contingent on many things being accurate
yeah and in my experience effective
lifestyle design is effective testing
and awareness investing
is for me at least has been effective
testing and developing keen awareness of
things that most people don't pay
attention to or a lot of people don't
pay attention to so if we're looking at
for instance living in New York City
yeah versus living in Austin someone
might say well I'm just going to live
here for another ten years I'm going to
have these falling promotions in my
investment-banking job and then I'm
gonna move to Hudson Valley I'm gonna
move to Santa Barbara I'm gonna move to
and then live the good life
sure you will right yeah so you that if
that is your life plan like let's spend
some time developing experiments to
prove or disprove that before you
dedicate the next 20 years to it but
people will very often spend more time
planning their Memorial Day weekend then
they will specking out tests right so if
you look at it say is there anything in
your historical record to suggest that
you will be able to walk away from
something like that right anything yeah
if you are type A Wrap and by definition
in that circumstance you're probably
type A
yeah and there are many many many many
faulty assumptions yeah so I think that
I I am very very accepting of the fact
that there are many things I don't know
and there are many things that I take
for granted and there are many things
that I don't see yeah therefore I spend
a lot of my time developing experiments
and that's that's my constant framework
like how can I be sure that I know X
yeah which you know relates to and 2015
walking away from start investing sounds
like all right if I look at the track
record of these various companies not
only in my portfolio but others for the
biggest wins it's taking we're looking
at say Shopify uber etc it's taking 712
years yeah to come to fruition and your
final tally is not known until you've
liquidated all of your holdings
effectively and yeah it's
a little more complicated than that but
but not by much so even though on paper
and also in exits it would I could
convince myself that I am good at this
and people tell me I'm good at this that
remains to be seen
yeah right and so I stopped and a larger
assumption just because you're good at
something does not mean you have to keep
doing it for the rest of your life yeah
there are many things I'm good at that I
shouldn't do at all yeah and it's I
think it's it's it's challenging for
anyone myself included to shift gears if
you if you're good at something being
rewarded for something and yet you have
this creeping dread that you don't want
to want to do it that that that is a
challenging situation for I think just
about anyone and certainly has been
challenging for me but the the parachute
right the the safety net is realizing
that for almost anything you can leave
and come back yeah almost anything and
I'm sure there are exceptions but if
we're talking about businesses and
professional capacities and careers if
you are really good that's a big that's
the ultimate leverage that's that is
that is a huge hurdle that you need to
be able to pass but yeah if you are
really good and dedicated to your craft
or crafts it could be a combination of
unusual crafts right right you might be
a quantum who's also really good at
writing and then you have a newsletter
sure it could be an unusual combination
of traits like Warren Buffett and public
speaking or writer or Jeff Bezos and
writing entrepreneurship etc you can
always come back right right it's so I
try to keep that in mind and making a
lot of my decisions you know what's
interesting it's like you're taking it
all very seriously
but then you're also not taking it that
serious so like I I was thinking because
we were talking about the Stokes more
like one of the things that sort of
weaves its way through I think with
thinking
you're giving and I know I gave you one
of these but the the momentum or like
like part one of the reasons you
shouldn't do the thing for the rest of
your life just cuz you're good at it is
you only get one life and one of the
reasons I think you're always
questioning that but it seems like part
of your fear setting thing is like what
if I die like does any of this matter
you know what I mean
yeah the costs of inaction yeah I think
that thinking very carefully about the
costs of inaction and telescoping out
six months 12 months 18 months you know
what effect does continuing to do what
you do have on you and your loved ones
from a financial emotional physical
perspective right yeah and I think about
death all the time and it's not a morbid
sullen exercise for me it's this becomes
easier as older you get because friends
start dying family members die and you
realize this is not an indefinite lease
yes you have or that it is at least you
don't own it yeah it is at least yes and
that having the I don't want to call it
time pressure but awareness of that
impermanence for me I find this might
sound strange but like greatly
encouraging because it drives a sense of
urgency yeah or at least time
sensitivity to a lot of my decisions and
so that's on one hand surprising this
fleeting yeah on renewable resource that
is time and realizing that doesn't
matter how much money you're willing to
pay on your deathbed you're not gonna be
able to buy back more time right and
then simultaneously
I guess meditating is the best way to
put it or contemplating
how little a lot of this matters or all
of it man yeah in so much as you know as
navall rava comment once said to me is
like yeah we're just a bunch of monkeys
on the spinning rocky and spending time
this sounds so highfalutin but whatever
reading about the cosmos or
contemplating as believe it was IDI
cook an incredible memory competitive
champion and entrepreneur memorizes his
company M EMR is EE and coach also
writer had said to me no he would and BJ
BJ Miller has a hospice care physician I
think did something very similar but
they would look at say the Stars and
imagine that it's possible and I'm not
an astrophysicist so maybe this isn't
possible about that it's possible that
the star you are seeing is in fact light
that is hitting your eye from a star
that no longer exists yeah right and to
just sort of contemplate that now you're
freaking out because you have some
problem with M X right or there's some
disagreement and it's like somebody
badmouth you at work or whatever it is
you're right okay to number one or
number two on the New York Times
bestseller list or you know all the
things that who cares yeah all dust yes
as our friend Marcus what's s like all
dust I get nobody gives a [ __ ] right
like it's not even you in the future
will give a [ __ ] it's yeah it's it's
it's all going to be it's just
completely irrelevant and so holding
those two in my mind has been a practice
and I do think about death a lot and
there was a person featured in I think
it was tribe mentors Moonee Valley who's
involved very heavily involved with
cryptocurrency and very very smart guy
might I may be better put blotchy and
very smart guy
and it's funny to me how certain things
stick and certain things don't stick or
certain things have like a time-release
okay so I read this nose like oh that's
interesting
yeah and then months later so it's
resurfaced and I've thought about it a
lot since which was he'll he will
routinely ask himself when he's over
whelmed or feeling scattered and how
much would I pay to relive this
experience like 20 years from now 30
years from now 40 years from now and I'm
paraphrasing yeah that's not not not
perfectly stated but and I think about
that we're all be if I think about the
experiences that I would pay the most
for and I'm being honest with myself
it's it's not the professional successes
or the glamour shots it's using
something very simple right like it's a
moments of stillness and quietness and
wakey-wakey waking up in bed with my
girlfriend on a like a beautiful sunny
day and like patting the padding the bed
and having my dog jump up right having a
little snuggle fest it's very it sounds
so cheesy like the 20 year old Tim would
just be vomiting all over himself right
now but nonetheless 20 20 roll tim is
pretty miserable [ __ ] so I feel like
I've improved on that front and asking
yourself all right if I were 80 and like
Molly has long since passed away
maybe my wife has passed away how much
would I pay for them
Yeah right and that really to me is part
and parcel of the valuing of time these
slivers of experience as more valuable
than making a speculative decision about
earning more in the future based on
doing something that say takes you away
from those people right or agreeing to
something because you might get some
honor or mm-hmm
you know ok Matt adds add one more thing
which is I really think that even if you
keep all your money in a mattress
studying good investors is worth a lot
yeah not necessarily in financial
but in temporal return right and ITIN in
in how you think about time yeah because
humans overall are very sloppy I'm no
mathematician so I'll put myself in the
same category when it comes to thinking
about probabilities yeah like
probabilistic thinking is not it's not a
strong suit for humans and so you might
hear like oh my god there's room of 300
people in like yeah these two people
have the same birthday that's crazy
yeah but like mathematically speaking is
not that crazy right and in fact at some
point it becomes totally expected yeah
and similarly developing a basic sort of
mathematical literacy with respect to
investing so I think most people
watching and listening this will have as
I did I mean I stopped taking math in
high school because that one bad math
teacher even though I was good at it I
became totally turned off my brother
went on to get a PhD in stats so and it
was the same year he had a good math
teacher and I had one who had just a
ballbuster and you can see how we split
in different directions but I've I have
a deep-seated insecurity when it comes
to math nonetheless
studying investing has helped me to
develop my understanding of certain
concepts like expected value so if you
think that you are going to you could
make a hundred thousand dollars or a
million dollars or ten thousand dollars
at Y point in time is making that
decision in your mind actually worth ten
a hundred thousand or whatever Mike yeah
well it depends a lot on the probability
of that happening right and then you can
do some basic multiplication you'd be
like all right
actually the expected value of that
given that it's low probability or fifty
percent of 30 percent is instead of a
hundred thousand dollars actually for
twenty five thousand dollars right that
could very very deeply influence how you
make that decision right now how you're
gonna spend your time over the next six
to twelve months right right sure
because if there's a sure bet it's a
fifty thousand dollar return but it's
8090 percent likely to happen it's one
it's more it's worth more right if
you're thinking about it in a structured
way
and there are some really fun books on
investing that don't necessarily touch
on this and exactly one is called more
money than god it's about hedge fund
investors it's a super fun book
it's kind of like liars poker yeah
instead of purely bonds it's yeah it's
all sorts of different characters and
types of investing there are other books
I think there's one called how to
measure anything which is worth taking a
look at I was recommended by co-founder
of ZocDoc
and Nick Ganju who is a fantastic
teacher really really good teacher he's
taught me a lot about music and math
math is too scary
just like how to think probabilistically
because life is probabilities yeah and
whenever for instance and I'm dragging
myself into the deep end a little bit
here because I'm not a scientist but if
you if you look at science and studies
you will very this is another reason to
become sort of probabilistic aliy
literate is you'll be better able to
separate fact from fiction and fact from
hyperbole in medicine and science people
get so confused about these things and
people end up dying and making bad
decisions right choosing quacky doctors
without this basic literacy there's
there's a great book called bad science
yeah by Ben Goldacre then I recommend
everybody I excerpted some of those
chapters in the appendix of 4-hour body
except that's so important but suffice
to say if someone says these studies
prove X it's not really true right
they're there they suggest at a high
probability just for a very small sample
size it has a slightly greater than
average probability that acne and it
could be an incredibly strong signal but
it is not a hundred percent certainty so
my never been replicated it might never
been replicated there could be
experimenter bias who knows how tight
the design was and it changes how you
relate to the world and decisions
and opportunities and risks when you
start thinking in terms of probabilities
right because to remove all risk is a
fool's errand yeah I spend a lot of time
trying to do that and chasing that tail
end of like the last let's just call it
ten percent of risk you could spend all
your time 24 hours a day every day
trying to do that and you would still
not succeed right you just have to lock
yourself in solitary confinement in the
box right it would be no life worth
living but this this has been a real
game-changer for me even though I don't
I don't do I mean I invest anyone who's
alive invest I think it's like you're
investing time and energy capital like
you're choosing where to allocate
resources but I read all these books on
investing or think twice is another one
that's good related cognitive biases not
because I'm playing the stock market
yeah at all all right that's not why I'm
reading this book I'm reading it because
it helps me to think in a more
structured way about good
decision-making yeah I want to come back
to the studying things that a question
for you but I was when we were talking
about sort of happiness money young old
SEP can bar who we both know yeah
brilliant guy he did this massive study
don't when he scraped all these blog
posts about like and social media post
about what people were saying is I think
the book is I feel fine this is like the
result of the findings but he was
talking about how young people when they
say like I feel happy it tends to be
followed with statements about
accomplishments or activity and as you
can older the statements drift steadily
towards feelings of contentment or
connectedness and so we can make a lot
of decisions it's like we know
objectively that's we're gonna end up
that's what we're gonna care about but
then we spend most of our lives focusing
on piling up accomplishments do you know
what I mean yeah and and sort of knowing
that I think that idea of thinking about
what you're gonna care about if you are
lucky enough to be it will get all
is really important because it puts the
things that feel important in
perspective
yeah it ceptin an amazing computer
scientist yeah and just a sweet the
heart of totally and this this
observation that you just made and that
in younger years let's just call it 20s
and maybe 30s or or early 30s
I am happy I'm doing great because and
then accomplishment yeah versus the
contrast with connectedness and so on
when older raises a lot of interesting
questions for me right so is it that
independent of how well someone does
professionally that that shift exists
yeah
or is it that those people who are being
polled happened to be it's a Stanford
where a set has spent a lot of time so
no people aren't being hope this is all
unsolicited ins that you make on social
media I guess so
so that that answers that these like to
me the it's important to me at least to
immediately not be a cynic but to ask a
lot of questions so I understand the
nature of what is being implied right
yeah because could it be that the people
who experience or value connectedness in
later years sort of paid their dues cut
their keys yeah and therefore they're
like alright I'm on my second home I
have checked off all these rungs on hot
Maslow's hierarchy of needs
sure great now I can focus on yeah you
know self-actualization or does happen
independently I think I think that if I
had to place bed I would imagine that it
probably happened somewhat independently
as you become more aware of your
mortality yes okay that's what it is but
the this is another facet that I think
underscores how beneficial it is to
study good investors and that is or good
scientists but it's it's
think that investing has more sex appeal
for a lot of people the distinction
between correlation and causation
yeah right and or is there a third is it
possible there's a third or fourth
factor yeah they could be causal or at
least highly correlated right so you
might see an observational study of some
type where women who do yoga between the
ages of this and this report a higher
level of well-being and yeah lower blood
pressure therefore the headline in some
huffington post wherever right there for
yoga decreases blood pressure right wait
a second where was this done yeah like
Oh San Diego okay what's the median
household income okay what else are they
doing oh they're seeing they have a PPO
instead of HMO and they're seeing some
of the best doctors in the country oh
okay all right
and you begin to realize how tricky it
can be to establish a causation right
yeah but I
I don't find at least the more I dig
into this stuff I find that more
enriching and exciting than anything
else I know that it's frustrating
because it means you can't rely on say
most media reports of scientific
findings or studies to be accurate and
the claims that are extrapolated but at
the same time to me what it highlights
is how much there is in plain sight that
is really misunderstood yeah
and that's exciting for me because to me
that says that spells opportunity if if
it's possible for instance and you know
there's pretty good examples of this I
think that if you even look at for
instance before we started recording
we're talking about the big short yeah
if we look at some of these more like
mortgage backed securities short bets
yeah ended up producing these
multibillion-dollar windfall some some
of those positions were based on looking
at publicly available data and drawing
some pretty
and sense conclusions right right it
wasn't what we think may I
proprietary AI from the Chinese
government that was cracking this code
it was looking at what's right in front
of certain people and seeing something
different and also asking a lot of
questions about incentives right right
like if you ask a venture capitalist if
things are going to turn south it's they
are highly highly highly highly highly
subconsciously or consciously just
incentivized from saying things are
gonna go south because they have a large
bet that things are gonna go south which
they would have to have yeah either
outside of venture capital right it
wouldn't be Coral it wouldn't be
associated with their fund or they'd
have to have some like counter-cyclical
startup bet which they may or may not
right conversely if you're looking at
say hedge fund investors and it's a term
that's falling out of favor but
nonetheless people who can place both
long bets we think this is going up or
growing and short paths we think this is
going down or decreasing value their
view the world is gonna be very
different you know what they're willing
to talk about yeah so there I find it
incredibly both really exciting and
entirely terrifying that there are so
many blind spots well Tyler Cowen talks
about this with the three point
revolution in the NBA
like 3-pointer has always been worth
more than two pointers right so you can
miss a higher percentage of them and
still score more points right like so so
it you know percentage making of a
3-pointer is on average worth more than
what other than a field goal right and
he's like literally people were paid
millions of dollars million billions of
fans watch this game and no one was like
hey why don't we shoot more
three-pointers right you know and and
then somebody did it and the entire game
changes yeah one other was a Steph Curry
or someone comes in it but like that it
was even not
like within our lifetime like it was
within the last half decade yeah that
the game fundamentally changed and it's
not like it's not like they figured out
the physics of shooting a three-pointer
better like yeah just now there's
incentives and so people shoot more
three-pointers and they make more and
that in game literally that millions of
people watch just nobody noticed this
thing right and from yeah
yeah or like you look at certain
inventions right wheels on luggage like
yeah Jonathan for God's sake Yeah right
how long does that take and it's it's
it's sitting there right in plain sight
yeah and I think there are still I mean
practically infinite number of
opportunities like that and for me at
least it all comes from just a better
set of questions and if you look at the
process behind or that has been
developed at places like I do or frog
design or these these different product
development industrial design firms a
lot of its asking questions right and
trying to not just test the assumptions
but find the assumptions identify the
assumptions you know something like
grocery cart design yeah right like what
if we just completely take me for
granted because this is the way it is
and this is the way it's always been
yeah and I find that really exciting
when it comes to it and I like to try to
ask a lot of those questions there's a
there's a great doc documentary called
objectified yeah which is about a lot of
this and then I saw it a long time ago
made by the same filmmakers I believe we
did a film called Helvetica about good
yes such a great doc that brings up a
lot of this and when I see something
that doesn't make sense or doesn't feel
good doesn't work well I like to ask a
lot of questions and also combine that
with studying incentives yeah I think is
there any reason besides a design blind
spot that there weren't wheels on
luggage earlier like is there some is
some one incentive
sure in such a way that would make that
look did that idea exist 30 years or
abut and never came to fruition and if
so why might that be the case okay let's
do that as a thought exercise yeah
and for instance I remember when uber is
a great example of this brand I mean I
was involved with uber before it was
called uber uber cab LLC way back in the
day like 2008 yeah and we'll just refer
to that as uber for simplicity was
widely mocked I mean I was it was put on
angel lists which is another company I'm
involved with angel Cove people on check
it out it was offered to investors and
turned down I want to say by hundreds of
investors as yeah ludicrous yeah and the
the math behind that some of the
ridicule looked at the existing market
for I want to say black sedan car
service right and limousines and in that
analysis in retrospect we can see there
are a bunch of false assumptions right
right they thought it was always gonna
be high-priced yeah where many things
start out being prototype among the
privileged yeah recycling you have a
great example of that but then with
scale prices go down
they also assumed a relatively fixed
market size like here's the existing
market of black sedan use we only see X
percent of single-digit growth
yeah this is a shitty business because
they'll never capture more than Y
percent right missing the the
possibility and ultimately the reality
which was that ride-sharing would create
expand that market exponentially create
its own market right and then you look
at let's just say incentives of media
coverage yeah right okay at the time and
even more so now it's in its very much
in fashion to sort of attack
it seems like it's catering to the 1%
right yeah no it's really critical to
prototype with people who are price
insensitive in the early stages of a lot
of product development because it can
subsidize if you're making one offs
they're gonna be [ __ ] expensive and
if you're testing things and there's a
it's very rough around the edges you can
have these rich people exactly subsidize
the product development that will
ultimately lead to mass adoption yeah so
I find the whole thing just endlessly
fascinating yeah and I think it's it's
also safe to assume it at almost any
given point in time that almost
everybody is getting it wrong yeah with
with many many many many many things and
that to me says that if you just have
because this is not an intrinsic
capability that I have this has been if
we're talking about it from an
investment perspective or opportunity
spotting perspective it is absolutely
something that I have honed over time
and there are many people much better
than I am by but I've I've when I found
questions I like I borrow those
questions and I put them into an
Evernote notebook yeah under investing I
have these questions when people point
out misperceptions to me and I'm like
holy [ __ ] I totally missed that how
could I have missed that I write those
down and like wow like I completely this
never would have occurred to me now that
they've said it it's it's entirely
self-evident like how how did I miss
that and why did they not wait why did
they not miss it yeah I really think
about these things and over time you can
develop this this very learnable skill
of seeing things that other people don't
see which for me is mostly a byproduct
of asking a lot of questions well that
actually ties in to what I was going to
talk to you about next there's a quota
and egos anime I ever call from Bismarck
races like any fool can learn by
experience I prefer to learn I the
experience of others and it seems like
like so you're doing experiments you're
you're truant you're doing trouser but
you're also at you it seems like that's
one bucket of learning for you then the
other bucket is like a network of smart
people you asked lots of questions of
and then the third one is like you read
widely and deeply from different kinds
of books from history from philosophy
from psychology so you're not spending
30 years of your life learning a lesson
you could have learned on a three-dollar
used Amazon purchase oh yeah I much
prefer to not make my own mistakes if I
can avoid it
recognizing that of course I'm gonna
make all sorts of terrible mistakes and
to give to give an example of the second
category yeah I'm learning from other
people and how I might approach that we
can talk about something we were
discussing very briefly before we
started recording which is right now
I've noticed and my team has noticed
some kind of odd behavior when it comes
to email deliverability and open rates
and we have a by most measures a large
list at 1.5 million or something like
that four or five bullet Friday in these
various newsletters and we could we have
already looked on Google we've already
talked to some of the parties involved
but these parties have various
incentives yeah that may or may not be
totally aligned sure with ours not to
say they're in any way malicious or
nefarious it's just different companies
different people different parties in a
different collaboration or transaction
at different incentives so I and my team
have been putting together an email
draft email to send to people like
yourself and it's really five or six
people I know already who have large
lists yeah to ask a handful of questions
but if I simply email all of you with a
handful of questions it's a very
one-sided interaction yeah right I'm
asking someone to take time out of their
day to help me with nothing in return so
what we've done is underneath each
question we are adding what we've tried
right like here here the here the three
things we've already tried to address
this here are the results but we're
still looking for more
what have you done or what would you do
right step one or question one question
two questions are your question four and
that could at some point turn into we
were joking earlier the conversion Cabal
registered trademark
I am funnel here we go I'm not going to
do that but the that could turn into
some type of brain trust sure with a
handful of people who then exchange best
practices right where everyone is
currently or most people are very siloed
yeah so they're all trying to solve
similar problems and have similar
aspirations yet even though all the
newsletters that I'm that I'm thinking
of which are owned by people like
yourself these other folks they're all
non-competitive they're all in different
areas with different demographics and it
would make a lot of sense to have some
information exchange and that will start
the initial volley will be this email
right where I'll share a bunch of stuff
and we may or may not get replies I hope
we get replies that would be an example
of trying not to just make our own
mistakes no I'm going tomorrow I'm
flying to Arizona and I'm meeting with
five or six authors who you know we go
to this house in Sedona
you know they've also each one of us
with hundreds of thousands of books
best-selling authors and we just shoot
the [ __ ] about stuff that's going on we
ask each other questions there and you
could even argue that some of us are
competitive I don't think books are
competitive but like the point is like
why would we compete where we don't need
to compete let's compete on like making
great stuff Elizabeth the other you know
what I mean like that's what's been
amazing for me with sports watching
these like coaches give book
recommendations to each other you like
you'd think they would be competitive
but it's like actually they're getting
the easy stuff out of the way and then
on Sunday they're competing yeah and so
just I think people can be really
precious with information when actually
you're almost always better sharing
information yeah and on top of that
I can very safely give my playbook for
almost anything right to thousands of
people
yeah and almost no one's gonna implement
any of I and that's not to say that
prescriptive how-to stuff doesn't get
used it does right particularly when
it's simple right likes low-carb diet
for our body hundreds of thousands of
people maybe millions and use this diet
successfully it's simple it's easy to
follow everyone is following a diet yeah
whether they choose to or not sure but
when it comes to say launching a book
yeah right and I lay out this monstrous
post because I got tired of answering
these questions as one officer how do I
think it's called how to publish a
best-seller how do how to publish a
best-selling book this year or something
like that I had a right of this song but
these are a camera for the exam oh but
it's this monster compilation post if
like everything you can imagine related
to writing prepping titling publishing
versus self publishing marketing PR yeah
all of it yeah blurbs do you name it
every stone is is turned and people
don't do it yeah if they're just like no
I want it I want the Silver Bullet easy
answer like can I hire someone to do
that for me yeah yeah it's like ya know
this is that I mean maybe you can but
like this is my blueprint right I've
used it repeatedly it works but guess
what you still have to write a [ __ ]
good book right and not to say my books
are the best in the world they're not I
mean you know I would like to see that I
would like to think they're very useful
but I'm not tall so I recognize there
are better writers out there nonetheless
I take the vast majority of energy and
it goes into the writing yeah but man
yeah it's it's it's pretty wild how
little adherence there is well the good
of that last bucket maybe that's a place
to wind up what do you think about
reading like how do you find what you
read what's your methodology for
breaking down books like
do where do you get the knowledge that
saves you painful trial and error I very
rarely read anything that isn't
recommended to me by either someone I
know is very selective and snobby about
book choice yeah
like Satan of all Roth con or my brother
yeah there are certain people who
already have such a tight filter that
anything anything they read has passed a
very high bar yeah and anything they
recommend has passed and even a higher
bar yeah that is one way I get books
referred to me that I take seriously
another would would be triangulating
multiple points of recommendation and
then very often what I'll do is let's
just say I get a book recommended from
people on social media yeah readers or
listeners and I will prompt
recommendations quite often by asking
for yeah the best books on a certain
topic and perhaps a year ago or two
years ago is very interested in learning
more about the contemporary art world
not just the artists but the gallerists
and the entire industry the market the
black box all the craziness that that
goes into that and this book called the
twelve million dollar stuffed shark
popped up repeatedly yeah like okay let
me take a look at that and I looked at
it seemingly written by an economist I
go down then on Amazon in this case to
the reviews I don't read the one-star
reviews because they're like I thought
this wasn't insta pot this is stupid
really not mine came damaged in the mail
yeah or it's just they didn't clearly
didn't read the description they're like
this wasn't a novel at all it's a dummy
it's not a novel so I I
I don't read the one-star yeah I don't
read the what is the highest 5 stars
yeah I don't read the 5 stars I will
read the most helpful 3
or star right because I already have the
gestalt if if the reviews are more than
a few hundred reviews I make the
assumption that it is more or less
reflective of the reality of the book
Amazon reviews can very easily be gamed
on a smaller level but most authors are
not going to be right motivated enough
to do it over a long period of time so I
assume if if there are hundreds of
reviews or even a hundred plus and I
look at them and there are substantive
reviews that the overall star star
ranking is it is it is a broad indicator
yeah of how much people have liked the
book then I look at the most helpful
three and four star reviews
because they will they will very often
be say three paragraphs to two pages
long and they will really accurately lay
out the structure of the book and like
the strengths and weaknesses it
sometimes they make you read the book
better because you know it sometimes it
spoils what's in the book but then you
actually understand it when you're
reading it yeah absolutely so I I do
that and if if at that point I'm
interested I download it on Kindle yeah
I try to do almost all of my reading on
Kindle which gives me the ability to
highlight very easily and then I can go
to notebook on Amazon or use any number
of other services to grab those
highlights and look at them on laptop
put them into Evernote whatever it might
be but before I get there I will look at
the most popular highlights I will also
look at Goodreads mmm I like looking at
Goodreads for quotes from given books if
you don't like if you don't love yeah
some of the quotes from the books
that's like hating the movie trailer and
then going to see a three hour movie
right you're not gonna like the movie
yeah so I look at Goodreads and let's
just say then I have the Kindle version
I will I'll read two chapters three
chapters and if I don't if I'm not
really grabbed if I don't want to take a
photograph of some of the highlights and
send it to
friend I will consider stopping reading
because life's too short
life's too [ __ ] short at that and
Timur been of wait but why has so many
great pieces and one is called the tail
end and he talks about the number of
books he's likely to read and the rest
of his life and it's a shockingly
frightening Lee yeah so I don't have
enough time left in my life if we're
assuming I'm gonna die and I've looked
at the the the death ages of my
grandparents great grandparents etc then
I've like isolated the males I've looked
at so there's a pretty decent chance
I'll die somewhere between 80 and 85 and
I'm 43 yes not that much time left
especially if you consider sort of
cognitive decline and so yeah right so
I've got let's just call it who knows
you know twenty to twenty or thirty
years left of my good book reading I'd
also get hit by a bus I could get hit by
a bus so all that is to say I don't have
enough time to even read the classics I
know the titles of right right that I've
heard of I don't have time for that
right I don't have time to read all
those so the idea that I would pick up a
book and and think to myself this is
pretty mediocre and dedicate a week to
reading it is pure insanity so I I drop
a lot of books when I looked at and I
put up a blog post recently looking at
everything I read in 2019 all the books
and favorite articles and I included all
the books I bought from Amazon and I
ended up completing somewhere between 30
and 40 percent of all the books that
already made the cut to that point that
I bought them sure sure
and some of those I simply just never
got around to but a lot of them I I
stopped I like the rule a hundred pages
minus your age that's that's the the
taste test yeah that's when you quit
okay so as you get older you become more
ruthless yes younger you have to give it
because you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about yeah I like that I
like that yeah I like that but no I
think people are they're like I
for this that that's the Sun cos palace
it's like I paid for this I should
finish it it's like you you hate this
books you're gonna give it hours of your
life weeks of your life yeah just to
prove that you could finish a David
Foster Wallace book I mean like come on
yeah and I'm just thinking one way you
could maybe trick yourself into making
better decisions with books is to
imagine that the book you're reading is
someone you're having dinner with yeah
and aside would you really sign up for
like five more dinners with this person
right if this is how you do while you're
reading it sure no you wouldn't
right and the call that you'd make up an
excuse and you'd leave the dinner you're
already at yeah exactly so books are
also a great way to procrastinate so a
socially validated way to procrastinate
yeah I try to be ruthlessly honest with
myself about that injury I will there
are a lot of great books out there yeah
I could spend all day every day reading
great books yeah and produce absolutely
nothing of value
yeah so I have increasingly tried to
block out time I have less I would say
less and less time I dedicate to reading
and I'm going to be publishing it posted
this week which is a public
pronouncement which helps with setting
policies for saying no describing why
I'm not gonna read any new books in 2020
so anything that is published in 2020 oh
that's my general rules that almost
always go towards older books yeah you
can I say one thing yeah so I'm gonna
put out that post also to hold myself
accountable
right right right because if I get
caught then reading something new makes
me look like a liar or hypocrite and I
use public the public learns I
I definitely don't don't won't want to
do those and don't want to do those so
this is a this is a single decision that
makes as Greg McEwan of essentialism
which is a great book I recommend we'd
say not do any more so not new
oh yeah yeah they had some fantastic
book looking for the single decisions
that remove hundreds of decisions right
so not reading any books in 2020 removes
a lot of decision so this is all I got
you should read this book it's new sorry
I can't do it right right it preserves
so much of my cognitive decision-making
bandwidth and the energy for other
things to make that one public and for
me public is to a large audience but for
in other areas of my life I make public
commitments to one or two or three
friends or my girlfriend so that they
can hold me accountable sure and I find
great value than that if you're trying
to guard against your lesser self I find
that really useful no and I think I
think with it's like so the cost of a
book is financial primarily time and
then what you're gonna put in your brain
I don't want to read things that are
gonna be subsequently or very quickly
proven irrelevant or proven you know
incorrect or out of fashion like you'd
be better off sitting down and reading
Shakespeare's plays because that is good
that has not only had 500 years of
cultural impact but we'll probably have
500 more years of cultural impact so
like I think looking at the half-life of
information and deciding to consume
information that's likely to remain true
over time it forces you to be both more
general but also more timeless meanwhile
if you read a book about the first year
the trump presidency where where how
many books it like like a couple years
ago or a year or so ago somebody wrote a
book about uber and then like the
founder was fired shortly after the book
came it's like that book is the guy who
finished that book wasted his time
because it's already irrelevant by
subsequent events and I think we have a
newness bias that prevents us from
accumulating wisdom where we could be
finding it yeah I am more interested
these days in the piece
is of the puzzle and by the puzzle we
could be talking about anything right
maybe talking about human behavior we
could be talking about the the rise and
fall of nations that are kind of like
the tectonic plates sure I'm more
interested in those because there's a
bit more certainty and a higher degree
of confidence in identifying and
understanding some of those elements
right if they've been shown over and
over again throughout history or proven
or I suppose they someone I said earlier
you know shown to be very likely
repeatedly in in science yeah so this
all makes me think of this quotes by I'm
thinking in the name right Donald Knuth
knu Thu was ad I want to say IBM might
be IBM but doesn't really matter the
point being he stopped using email at
one point yeah completely stopped and he
said for people who want to stay on top
of things email is great he's like but
but I want to get to the bottom of
things and I've thought about that a lot
yeah
because keeping on top of things is a
losing game yeah it's just by definition
yeah it's happening it's a losing game
and there are people are gonna be more
dedicated and obsessive with current
affairs
I have no competitive advantage I have
no information advantage I've so I
actually have a lot of information
matters but I have no desire or
behavioral advantage with current events
but and it also breeds sort of
emotionally and physically a life driven
by cortisol and FOMO and so on whereas
if I'm able to discipline myself enough
which I partially do through this public
accountability to focus on studying
things that have endured
I just feel much better in life in
general and
make better decisions yeah look that
they didn't have the news 250 years ago
yeah they did fine yeah yeah yeah yeah
they did fine yeah they did just by
himself and yeah the news happy to miss
the news yeah of course of course I'd
rather have a truth than trivia yeah so
Ryan I suppose this is the time when we
say goodbye yep
with tearful tearful stoic holiday
goodbye yeah where can people find you
online learn more about you and what
would you like to tell people about your
current projects
yeah maybe check out daily stoic which
is a stoicism inspired email each
morning also at daily stoic on most
platforms and then I'm Bryan Holaday
pretty much any bookstore across the
socials and across shows yes sir any if
people look at your selection of books
and think of themselves I don't know
where to start
yeah where would you suggest people
start with your writing so good question
I'd start with the obstacles of the way
or stillness is the key depending it's
like if you're going through something
tough I'd start with the obstacles the
way if you're maybe dealing with some of
the stuff we're talking about which is
sort of life optimization what am i why
now do I manage maybe I do stillness all
right yeah and there you have it folks
Thank You Ryan yeah and as those
listening probably know this Tim Ferriss
signing off for now thank you for
listening and until next time experiment
well experiment widely and test those
assumptions
you